well we can expect some fireworks on the
ice next week as the golden knights
kickstart the playoffs vegas now set to
start round one
against a team they've struggled against
this season sports director chris
matthews live in studio now with a full
preview of the start of the playoffs i
can't believe it's already here brian
it's been fun we found out tonight the
vegas golden knights will be the number
two seed in the west and will open
against the minnesota wild
right here at t-mobile arena sunday at
noon now this is a team that has given
the knights fits right from the very
beginning way back in 2017
this year the wild were five one and two
against the team from up north
knights did outscore the wild by one
goal but they've been great games mark
stone led the way with
10 points against the wild mark andre
fleury was three and three against
minnesota robin leonard
0-1-1 now the wild are balanced and
confident
we find that when you play good teams
like that great teams uh
you raise up you raise up your play a
little bit and uh
you know just emotional games against
them it's always been fun it's always
been
back and forth we know like you said we
have played them
a lot of times this season and i think
we know how how to play them to be
successful and
we get a we got to work together and be
smart and
at the same time play play aggressive i
think we play our best game
when we play aggressive oh man it's
going to be a lot of fun